so now what's happening so now he called
out you know Logan plays like Logan
Logan Paul Jay Paul five of you and the
weirdest thing was in the Logan Paul
video where he announced that this was
happening yeah he was like and then
after the fight ksi called me out for no
reason at all brother no reason dude
yeah he did you not been just like
watching the news about yourself
yeah or just have you not been tuned in
uh yeah the shitty stuff you've been
doing yeah the whole world is [ __ ]
you calling you up for no reason
yeah he wants to fight me for everyone
wants to [ __ ] fight you yeah the
language he used in that video is so
shitty like he's just like you know I'm
the victim
whatever yeah he knows what he's doing
so they're gonna fight and so I started
you know I'm just doing research and
I've talked to you about a little bit
about this but I'm like he is buddy
posted snaps of him training in the
Mayweather gym and his boxing does not
look good really it's not a good first
day he's like doing this weird like
leaning forward thing and the trainer is
like no no no no no you stop doing that
that's you know and I just think like
his the wrestling background might be
hard to get around in this short of time
because ksi is like he's been boxing for
a minute and he's got knockout [ __ ]
power dude yeah there's videos of him
knocking oh yes yeah knocked out his
training partner granted that guy didn't
look like he was a great box or either
he kind of his hands were kind of down
and he was open but like and I'm not
gonna say ksi is like an amazing boxer
but he's got the switch I keep saying
that like he's got that killer instinct
you know Joe Weller is bleeding out of
his nose and no part of chaos I felt bad
that round 3 went off KS I walked over
the other side and [ __ ] just domed
him up bang bang bang he did not care
cuz imma kill this fool so he has that
switch and and like I see Logan like
trying to amp himself up in these videos
like looking you know I'm a savage you
know a buck boost I'm a beast
come on maverick now play by the rule a
beast a beast of a beast I'm a beast I'm
not
I'm not gay I hate how he just tried to
repurpose the Westside symbol as the
maverick symbol it's the so cringe he is
the [ __ ] from you got served he
just steals other people's from my bag
orlimar it's all in my [ __ ]